climate change in the mountains of
Switzerland is yielded an amazing
discovery it's allowing a new generation
of historians to learn about a world war
two military plane that until now had
been a secret kept in a glacier Debora
patta has the story
it is one of the most impossible stories
in aviation history the 1946 emergency
landing on a Swiss glacier of a US Army
plane carrying American officers and
their families the ghostly relics of the
aircraft have resurfaced over 70 years
later scattered by the elements and
exposed by the scorching temperatures
sweeping Europe that melted the glacier
the dakotas pilot was forced to make the
perilous landing to avoid crashing the
plane for four days rescue flights
braved treacherous weather searching for
survivors and then reserved almost by a
miracle but the kotel a half buried in
snow and 10,000 feet up on a storm swept
mountainside the 12 passengers including
an 11 year old child had huddled in the
plane trying to keep warm in sub-zero
temperatures then at last the rescue
party of swiss Mountaineers made their
way to the dakota the rescue marked a
milestone in aviation history two swiss
pilots flew reconnaissance planes fitted
with skis to land on the ice and pick up
the stranded Americans two at a time as
for the reunions well they certainly
we're good to see general Snavely greets
his wife experts continued to be
astounded to this day that everyone
survived the ordeal for CBS this morning
Saturday Debora patta London an amazing
discovery after all this time yeah a
remarkable that they survived you